[Musique]
on sortait très peu de jeu ne vaut
jamais je veux dire jamais pourquoi vous
n'êtes pas obligé par le temps combien
main et puis de toute façon j'ai eu
l'impression d'être des canucks aussi
mère de famille tuée l'impression d'être
considérés comme pas dire le mot pour un
animal mais une reproductrices c'est
tout une panne femmes
g comme tout le monde qu'on pas une
femme de société pas ce que la réalité
très loin de ce que vous espériez que
faisait-il très jeune en plus très loin
qu'est ce que vous souhaitiez d'abord on
va quand même un peu moins d'enfants
pour pouvoir les élever mieux c'est un
peu pénible à dire mais avoir eu un
soutien moral beaucoup plus plus sûres
du côté de mon mari il cause de moi
c'est un brave homme et ne vende pas
tout à fait les mêmes cités il a les
pieds sur terre c'est tout sur terre
mais je peux pas expliquer ça
si vous aimez très simple très c'est un
travailleur c'est depuis combien de
temps êtes vous mariée depuis le 14 août
comment vous êtes-vous connu à nice de
malta et caféine
je suis simple de hunter ce café et
quelques compagnons at il été pour vous
il ya eu du bon et du mauvais beaucoup
de buts chaque d'un front de sa qui sait
si ça m'était platine la platitude moi
ça m'aurait pas plu et avec ses enfants
comment at-il été bon père oui il est un
peu papa galère on m'appelle ils le
savent ça les amuse un peu mais il aime
bien moi je suis le président de la
république a lâché le ministre des
finances donc c'est à elle a géré la
maison ma foi bien des fois la gère avec
au dessus de possibilités mais elle se
débrouille quand même mois si vous aviez
eu la possibilité d'intervenir pour une
interruption de grossesse qu'est ce que
vous auriez décidé là je leur répondais
d'interrompre je ne peux pas être contre
son père si vous aviez une fois vous
auriez eu combien d'enfants
si j'avais le choix je leur prouve le
plus au trot 4 16 go maximum me disent
quand maman mais échange de tout le dire
michel c'est un très gentil garçon
c'est mon aîné c'est peut-être pas mon
chouchou parce que je les aime tous
pareillement fin michel nous nous sommes
très proches tous les deux il est très
gentil il va bientôt se marier adorable
petite jeune fille petite chantal mais
je crois qu'ils sont très heureux
quelles réactions avez vous à chaque
nouvelle naissance puisque vous avez
assisté à toutes les naissances un peu
de tristesse un peu de tristesse
non d'abord la jour la joie c'est
l'épicerie de fous plus on rit comme dit
souvent chênois d'abord la joie puis en
prenant de l'âge c'est un petit peu
transformés d'abord leur gré a là encore
nos bouches à nourrir
et puis un regard d'un est toujours pas
pâli travail bon vivement et ensuite
l'espace tourisme est bon même si je
l'étais pas dire c'est pour ça que je
suis resté à la maison
je suis le dernier à rester à la maison
c'est un peu pour subvenir modeste
participation mais c'est surtout pour ça
je ne suis peut se répéter qu'il va
passer tout seul
non je ne fais pas céder vos paroles
vieillesse je dis parce que j'étais
fatigué je disais à ma mère que je
voulais être
tandis que j'arriverai à tout ça que je
suis mariée j'ai pensé que j'avais un
devoir une tâche à accomplir et j'ai
voulu la combe l'accomplir envers et
contre tous je voulais quand même
seconde et mon avis dans le meilleur
possible
j'ai voulu que les enfants se sentent
bien chez eux malgré l'atmosphère où
nous vivons enfin donner une atmosphère
qui ne soit pas d'atmosphère matériel
soit plutôt à l'atmosphère de tendresse
moi j'étais très bien dans le moment
terrible lors des moments terribles
n'était pas malheureux
je m'attends et un noël formidable pape
a été malade et puis lui du monde
les souris par tf1 pour le noël
s'annonce et tristan noël sans achat
maintenant avec des morceaux de chiffons
confectionner des petits éléphants
déjouant un chiffon rempli de suivre
d'autres chiffres je crois que
l'explosion s'était les formidables des
vacances vous en avez presque jamais
jamais de vacances
je suis j'estime qu'elle en bas du dos
et qu'il se sont dévoués à leurs
familles de notre naissance de la
naissance du premier jusqu'à amener ces
derniers n'ont pas eu le temps de
profiter humaine vous avez suivi des
grossesses successives je n'en pouvais
plus je ne sais pas j'étais comme une
corde au bout d'un précipice j'avais
l'impression que ça allait craquer
sentais pas de mots c'est un beau monde
je n'avais plus de force
c'est mon petit lionel je n'en pouvais
plus qu'est ce que vous allez faire
j'ai demandé au docteur docteur m'a dit
c'est un vibro mais il va falloir opérer
et puis au moment de l'opéra dans
l'opération il était le père docteur db
si on peut faire quelque chose pour le
prime et c'est pas possible
en fait ce n'est pas et puis au moment
de l'opération se sont aperçus que j
avais une grossesse m'a dit on ne peut
rien faire
continuez j'ai eu mon lionel lionel
c'est un bon garçon un malheureux
maintenant puisque diminué par son
accident
ce que c'est agréable d'être le fils
d'une famille nombreuse de bruno le
sauvetage les corréziens quoi comme une
grande famille normale quels sont les
inconvénients alors de chasse et bruyant
quoi moi qui ai su pour le calme an plus
tôt qu'est ce que c'est que d'être un
fils de famille nombreuse prouver que
c'est bien d'avoir beaucoup de frères et
soeurs ainsi fait plaisir si vous aviez
pu choisir j'aurais aimé voir combien de
presevo personnellement 34 plus haut
bâtiment
dites-moi ce que c'est difficile d'être
une fille de tamina maintenanciers
coutume aussi aux coutumes au début même
par n'ont même pas tant donné que je ne
suis pas arrivée la lumière j'étais pas
la première des cours qu'ils s'agissent
mois
ça m'a pas gêné non pas du tout au
contraire quel effet ça fait d'être le
neuvième enfant d'une famille nombreuse
parce que presque rien tu comptes en
abattant deux frères et soeurs moi aussi
on peut s'amuser
oui est ce que tu te rends compte des
problèmes qu'ils ont eue pour vous elle
avec 12 oui comment tu t'en as pas si on
n'était pas tous league
il aurait moins de problèmes si on a
moins peur vous êtes arrivé d'avoir faim
oui j'ai mangé de l'herbe pour que
manger les enfants mais bien souvent il
ya un bris au début considère ici il
faisait mauvais temps et mon mari
travaillait la terre et quand il fait
mauvais temps doit pas travailler 21
membres et et donne son travail et les
boulangers intérêts qui sont offerts des
crédits à des gens comme nous puisque
nous étions déjà il avait déjà trois ou
quatre enfants et vous savez bien les
intestins la famille déjà nombreuse
alors pensé que j'aurais sûrement de
difficultés pour se faire payer alors
j'ai eu des difficultés et pour que les
enfants - je gardais le pain pour eux si
je faisais une assiette de soupe une
casserole d'eau sont pour eux pour eux
et pour mon mari pour qu'il puisse aller
trouver du travail bien s'il en reste et
le soir je garde le fond de la casserole
s'il arrêtait pas je vais vous dire des
herbes manger l'herbe
dans le pont c'est le métier le plus
beau le métier de mère de famille
y'a pas mieux ce que vous avez vous
pensez avoir réussi avec vos enfants
aucun n'a déçu oui j'ai dû déception
enfin ils se sont arrangés et garder du
travail qu'on arrive à arranger quand
même est-ce que quand vous vous sentirez
les la vieillesse très proches vous vous
direz vous pouvez vous dire ils sont
tous à l'abri je peux m'en aller
tranquille je l'espère c'est ce que je
souhaite je jouais arriver à ça nous
avons les appels reçus principal est la
seule chose qui compte
vous n'êtes pas complètement oubliée
vous existez vous qu une machine d'un
prompt une machine à faire des gosses
comme on m'a dit une marche est une
machine bien graissée qui travaillent du
soir au matin qui n'a qui n'a pas trop
de distractions d'empathie simple qui
s'ancre est tellement je ne suis pas
malheureuse non non non non tout pas
dire des bêtises non j'aime mais enfin
c'est ma joie ne veut pas dire des
bêtises voudraient les voir heureux
pas malheureux comme moi parce que je ne
souhaite même pas à mon pire ennemi mais
j'aimerais les voir bien heureux
j'espère que j'aurai
[Musique]